I've produced a lot of these Sadler
stories videos and of course released
them here in YouTube many of you have
seen quite a few of them and perhaps
commented on them or shared them or
stuff like that but one thing I've never
actually talked about in this series is
the story about how I got started with
YouTube in the first place and what the
first few years were like for me the
decisions that I made and why I did
things the way that I did maybe even
some of the lessons that I learned along
the way and I have told this story you
could say peace meal sometimes as
answers in amas or when I'm asked about
it in interviews but I don't think I've
ever sat down and actually just like
narrated the entire thing so this could
be interesting and useful perhaps for
some people obviously you don't want to
take this
as a blueprint for how to start a
YouTube channel because the situation is
very different now than it was back in
those Wild West days of YouTube when it
was first coming on the
scene and I should mention that when I
say that I don't mean like the very
origins of YouTube I effectively got
into using YouTube around 2011 I may
have uploaded some stuff earlier than
that I I'm not quite sure I'd have to go
back and and check but um so I'm going
to tell you the story and a lot of the
story at the start is
essentially uh my at that time fiance
now wife Andy Shaka being sort of an
early adopter of technology and you know
saying you should try this out and me
being sort of a stick in the mud uh not
politically but temperamentally
conservative and saying it'll never work
why should I do this sort of thing and
then actually trying it and being kind
of at first surprised then amazed and
then heartened by the results so there's
a couple different inroads and and they
all have to do with using a what was
called a flip cam there was an actual
company called flip that made a very
small portable camera that it was called
flip cam because this little arm would
flip out and had a USB thing on it you
could plug it into your computer and
download the video footage the files off
of it and then you know edit them in in
that and you know some of the later
models you could upload in other ways
right but generally you would just do it
by connecting it to your
computer so Andy bought me a flip Cam
and this was quite a while back this was
originally so that I could record time
that I was spending with my kids on a
summer vacation with them and we did
some of that um the flip cam didn't have
like really great capacities as far as
like video cameras go but it was you
know pretty good for the moment and they
were very very cheap and why did Andy
know so much about them well she was
always on top of technology to begin
with but she was also heavily involved
at the culinary Institute of America
with the educational technology Wing she
would eventually she was an assistant
Dean at the time and then eventually
would be the founder of the center for
excellence in teaching and learning and
this is a kind of thing that you have at
colleges in universities and institutes
where it's the people who help the
teachers become better teachers and a
lot of that is introducing them to
cuttingedge technology and so you know
YouTube was kind of a small at the time
the idea of recording lectures and then
uploading them and providing them as
researches flipping the classroom was
just coming into you know prominence it
not I won't say coming into being so
Andy you know uh had a good idea about
what you could use flip cams for and my
last semester at fville State University
where I was typically teaching a lot of
critical thinking classes she suggested
Ed to me that I should get a what we
call a spider tripod it's a very small
tripod that you could you know move the
legs out easily and you just screw the
flip cam onto it you plunk it down on a
desk uh and then you just start
recording right she said why don't you
start recording your class
lectures and you know providing them as
resources to your students you can
upload them in YouTube you can put them
in other places and actually at that
time where to go with your lectures was
kind of a problem because you know the
institution itself didn't have the
storage capacity for uploading things
and just storing them on their servers
so YouTube was a place to go but YouTube
at that time was only allowing
individuals to upload at first 10
minutes then 15 minutes then 20 minutes
videos that's why when you see those
really old YouTube videos and it'll say
like part one of six right that's
because they had to put a stop to it
institutions like fville State
University could have much longer upload
so that's when you know in Philosophy
for example Yale had its Yale courses uh
for example Shelly Kagan on death and
they could be much longer right so I had
the flip cam I had the classes to you
know teach in uh had a classroom that at
8:00 was fairly engaging with the
student students and the lighting was
decent enough and I told the students
this is what we're going to do I had
them sign fura releases that's a a law
that protects students privacy and I
said listen your voices might be on this
but you're not going to have your faces
or anything it'll just be me in front of
the truck board and this will be helpful
because if you miss a class or you have
to skip for some reason a medical
appointment going to court you know
dealing with your kids then you can
watch it later and if you want to go
back to it you can also watch it later
as well and so that's one thing I
started doing and those videos are not
actually in my channel they're in fville
State University's Channel and I also
recorded a few other lectures that I did
at the time that W wound up in fville
State University's Channel I think that
they U are probably the most watched
videos of all time in their Channel they
didn't really do much with with video
afterwards
unfortunately uh but I had a good person
to work with Susan Hazeltine I would
record my class lecture and then come in
download it shoot it over to her uh
through you know email I think it was or
maybe some sort of file uploading device
and then she would load it into YouTube
and then I would use it as a resource
for my students so that was going on I
also started shooting shorter videos
about like 15 to 20 minutes that I
called Dr Sadler chalk and talks
basically because all the educational
experts at the time who wanted to say
something about video we telling us
stupid things that they had no grounds
for buying into like you can't make a
video longer than five minutes or
students just won't watch it right which
turns out to be complete nonsense they
didn't know what they were talking about
they were just talking out of their
proverbial butts or they would say
things like oh it's got to be high
production nobody wants to watch
somebody in front of a chalkboard
writing things on the board and
lecturing chalk and talk is dead so I
was like okay we're going to do chalk
and talk and we're going to see whether
or not people will watch it and those I
did upload in my channel and then there
were a few conferences that I did
presentations at and some invited
lectures as well where I would set up
the camera and record what I was doing
for those
too so
interestingly the stuff in my channel
took off people liked it people
responded people started subscribing
people were like yeah this this guy is
actually worth watching you know the
video quality isn't great the sound
quality isn't great the lighting isn't
perfect there's pauses in there there's
a hiss that you can hear from the air
conditioning or whatever it happens to
be but we like what he's shooting so
we'll watch him and keep on going with
this and in the fville State University
Channel those critical thinking videos
just took off people started watching
them all over the world and commenting
on them and this is the really cool part
sometimes they'd be asking questions
they'd be like I didn't understand this
could you explain this a little bit more
sometimes it would just be like oh man
thanks this is awesome I love this right
but a lot of the comments this is the
stuff that kept me going were things
like thank you so much for posting this
I am in a class studying critical
thinking and my instructor won't explain
this stuff or I can't understand
anything this person says or you know
they don't seem to know what they're
talking about and you do that was
helpful then there were another set of
comments that were really important to
me and have remained very important to
me throughout my my work it's from
people who either went to college and
and missed that being in the classroom
experience and wanted to brush up on
stuff or more commonly people who were
working or had other obligations and
could not afford in terms of time or
money to go to college and they would be
like thank you for putting this out
there you know this is a free resource
that I can use to better my own
understanding um I can't afford to go to
school right now or maybe ever so you
are giving me the possibility at least
with this one thing that we're studying
here to learn something and that meant a
lot to me so you know long story short
that my time at fville State University
came to an end uh because I left there
to go up and and uh move in with Andy in
Kingston New York uh we Consolidated all
of our books into this tiny little
apartment
and you know we were engaged at the time
we got married that fall while she was
still working at The Culinary and I was
teaching at Marist College in pipy so
both on the same side of the river just
right up the road from each other we'd
often carpool to work and at Marist
because I was now teaching in a
philosophy Department no longer just in
a philosophy program that mostly did
critical thinking but a real philosophy
Department I had a wider range of
classes that I would
teach so I was teaching mostly uh intro
to philosophy and ethics and intro to
philosophy can really be uh done in a
lot of different ways so can ethics and
I like to focus on key thinkers and
texts and do things sometimes in a
either thematic or chronological way so
what I did is I was like okay we're
going to read these texts they're all
public domain you you know I'll give
them to students and I asked um can I
have permission to record these uh these
class sessions and my boss my chair was
like yeah I don't see any problem with
that make sure you get a furer release
right and there was some worries that
like at that time lecture capture if you
do it then students will stop coming to
class because you know they they already
know they can just like watch the videos
and again the educational experts turn
out to be completely wrong as a matter
of fact students wanted to be in the
class because they wanted to actually
get to ask questions while we were
shooting video or get to talk it it
promoted discussion and these became
really invaluable resources for me
because I could record the class session
and if students missed it I could be
like hey um check out the video right
well it's it's uploaded in your course
management system
or later on when I was teaching the
class again I could use the videos as
resources and again at that time all I
was really doing was recording an entire
class session I would plunk the camera
down and just let it run I wasn't using
a mic so the sound quality wasn't great
but you know it was it was decent right
and again I had the same sort of
response now I was uploading these in my
channel and my channel started to
increase exponentially in terms of views
in terms of how much time people were
watching it in terms of sharing in terms
of subscribers I mean it was slow at
first because it was a small
Channel and you know I always thought
well I'm kind of a nobody but one of the
cool things about YouTube is it's a big
equalizer right if you have good content
people are going to watch it I mean
they'll watch all the stuff that's high
production as well where they're
spending thousands of dollars on
videography or where you know at the
elite institutions they have people come
in with big cameras and handle all that
for you but if you're a DIY sort of
person like myself you could break in if
you knew what you were talking about and
your audience you know resonated with
you in some way and I I like to think
that my lectures are engaging and
interesting and that I know how to reach
Ordinary People um so you know they were
they were taking off and I was getting
the same sort of comments thank you for
posting this you know and then I started
getting a different kind of comment and
this is what led to me changing things
up hey um do you think you could shoot
videos on this person I know you've
already got videos on this person over
here but what about this thinker and so
I did a kind of
polling and I found that the top four
people that my subscribers and viewers
at the time were looking for were Jean
paulart Martin haiger uh gorg friederick
wilam Hegel and Herbert maruza all
Continental thinkers and so I thought to
myself you know I'm getting pretty
interested in existentialism I was like
rereading a lot of the texts that I used
to be into when I was a undergraduate
and early in my graduate career you know
and I was like you know I could probably
do a whole series on
existentialism so why don't I do that
and I started finding empty classrooms
no longer just recording what I was
doing in my classes but deliberately
recording videos about stuff that I
wasn't talking about in my classes some
of which I would use for later
classes um
and those really took off so
existentialism sart haiger but also k
guard and n and doeski and Marcel and
deir and kamu and Kafka and people like
that shestov fit into that spectrum and
then I thought I do want to do Hegel I
don't know about maruza maybe I'll do
him down the line um still haven't done
that yet but with Hegel I don't know
that I can do these summaries like I'm
doing I should do the phenomenology of
spirit because that's what most people
are really into although that's not the
best place to start with ha
and I'll just focus on the
phenomenology maybe I should do a close
reading you know line by line not skip
anything because it's too easy to skip
over the hard stuff and say ah do some
hand waving yeah you'll figure that part
out no let's let's do the whole thing
that's when I started the half hour
Hegel project this incredibly
complicated thing that I thought would
somehow only take me two or three years
took me nine years granted I had some
you know other things going on at the
time but um so maybe I could have
finished it in four or five but it's
still a lot of work over 370 videos in
the series roughly 25 to 35 minutes each
going through every single line line by
line explaining it all so that's another
thing that I did and that that also drew
a lot of attention I just finished that
up this year so that that's kind of a
cool accomplishment and then I started
shooting another kind of video quite
deliberately you know most of my videos
by this time were around anywhere from
40 minutes to an hour and 15
minutes and the half hour Hegel was a
little bit shorter and I started
thinking you know I should shoot shorter
videos on specific ideas or topics or
issues or arguments or distinctions
we'll call those core concept videos
I've shot over a thousand of those at
this point in time ranging from the
presocratic all the way up to 21st
century philosophy and I started doing
those originally for my students in my
classes again to try to help them out
and make things more clear for them
providing them resources that they could
go back to and I was like instead of
like having them make having them go
through an entire hour let's just say
we'll we'll do like 15 minutes to 20
minutes on this particular thing and
then I can link to it and then it's
easier for them to get into so I started
doing that and those also provided me
with the basis for the sadders lectures
podcast where I just take core concept
videos and and you know uh edit the
sound make it a little bit better take
out all the filler words and pauses and
repetitions of words and create new
sound files for them or I also use them
in classes both my academic classes I
use them a lot for those and for open
enrollment classes that I offer in the
study with Sadler Academy so I started
doing
those and by that time we're talking
about like you know
2014 I was finding that my channel was
growing uh considerably and it was
interesting too at one point in time it
looked like maybe I could even
potentially make a living shooting
YouTube videos now that didn't pan out
uh the most that I ever made was
probably about
$800 in a particular month uh it was
increasing and increasing and increasing
and then there was a crash and it wasn't
because people weren't watching my
videos anymore it was because YouTube
changed its algorithm and its payment
structure and a lot of people who had
actually gone all in were like holy crap
my business is is you know floundering
I'm gonna fail you know how am I gonna
cover my duts how am I going to pay my
marriage my my mortgage and I was like
kind of glad I didn't get that big that
quick and didn't go all in on this and
it's so it's always been kind of like a
sideline it's never made a ton of money
but it's it's always you know a bit and
it's it's kind of cool that it's there
um but you know it it showed me that the
the videos could also be useful for
other things you know people would watch
my videos and then be like I want to
hire you to be a tutor I want to hire
you to be a coach I want to hire you to
help me out with this so the videos have
been a way in which people got to know
me and got to know how I teach about
things and what sort of capacities I
have and I've built up a kind of ethos
of being somebody who isn't going to BS
you who's going to give you the strength
great stuff and isn't going to worry an
awful lot about Glitz and Glam and
making things easy I'm going to dig in
and make things accessible you know
available to Ordinary People and other
people professionals academics students
lifelong Learners and I won't talk about
stuff unless I actually know what I'm
talking about unlike so many other
people out there doing philosophy in
YouTube so that's that's how the channel
really got started and you know I've
added a lot of other things along the
way including these Sadler stories amas
all sorts of other cool stuff I could go
on and on and on but the core of what I
do is taking um ideas mostly from
philosophy also from religious studies
politics History Literature few other
things as well psychology
education and you know thinking about
how I can help other people understand
and appreciate and sometimes even apply
those that's what I do and it all got
started back in
2011 now at this point 12 years ago uh
actually more than that because it was
the beginning of 2011 so almost 13 years
ago and uh if if it hadn't been for me
being involved with my fiance Andy shock
I'm willing to bet that I probably
wouldn't have given it a chance and my
whole trajectory of my career might be
very very different than it it currently
is where producing videos is something
that I do nearly every day and have been
doing for so long that it's become kind
of second nature to me and I'm happy
that I I did it I wish it was a little
bit more you know remunerative but uh it
is what it is and I've been pretty
fortunate that I came around at this
time in our development of Technology
where I could talk to people all over
the world and again if it hadn't been
for my wife uh
Andy really egging me on helping to
overcome the initial objections worries
qualms and supporting me the whole way
uh probably you wouldn't be seeing me
here on YouTube so that's that's
probably enough of the story there's
much more that could be told but this
one's already getting a little bit long
so let's call that the official origin
story of the Gregory B Sadler Channel
and we'll end it right
here